now it may not be the most important
thing right now but the crisis has
obviously had a huge impact on Sport
Wimbledon was cancelled yesterday and
the Grand National will not be going
ahead on Saturday those two events alone
could involve three-quarters of a
billion pounds or Formula One possibly
the most commercial sport in the world
has canceled the first eight races in
the calendar but Formula One teams are
doing their bit we spoke to McLaren
about ventilators earlier in the week
and Mercedes is working with the NHS to
supply breathing equipment to all my
next guest knows Mercedes f1 because he
won the world championship with them in
2016 he now champions investments in
green technology having found it to the
Greek the green tech festival marking
speeds in that life from it B thirst
Nico Rosberg welcome to you Nico what
sir your assessment of how the f1
authorities have handled this crisis my
former team because it just shows the
technical and engineering excellence
that we have in formal Awan it's just
it's second to none how quickly mercedes
has now been able to develop
I mean produced and developed this
breathing Aid which essentially is going
to save many many lives and that's
really wonderful and I'm very very
impressed but what about the
cancellation of the events themselves
Nico Lewis Hamilton said that some races
should have been cancelled earlier than
than they were do you agree with that I
think they did they did a fair job I
mean it's always difficult you have to
measure there the pros and cons and and
I think eventually they did cancel in
Australia and and so they've done a good
job and and put the health of everybody
on top of everything else of course it
was a big disappointment as well at the
same time for all of us fans around the
world because we're so excited to see
the first race go ahead and to finally
see what's what but health always comes
first and and so they're doing the right
thing you know certainly as you say
Mercedes producing breathing equipment
for the NHS I mean this crisis really
has showcase the technological abilities
of the f1 teams hasn't it
I totally as I said they are just so
incredibly good and not only the
breathing aid that Mercedes is developed
now also all the f1 teams have joined
forces it's called Project pit lane
and they're now gonna be producing
ventilators as well because as we know
there's a huge shortage in ventilators
so this is going to be the next step now
coming shortly and that's as I said you
know that I'm super proud and and yeah
amazing that they're doing that well as
I said in the introduction since you
left f1 you've been champion championing
investment in green technology do you do
you worry that that's gonna fall away on
the back burner with this coronavirus
crisis I mean we've just seen cop 26
council for example certainly in the
short term yes the focus rightly so is
now on fighting this virus because that
is the most important matter for our
health and globally but then I think
after corona and there will be a time
after corner hopefully very very soon
after that I do believe that the
environmental issue is gonna jump right
back up to the top of the agenda again
because this is the decade which is
crucial and myself in all my business
endeavors I'm very much focused on being
involved in helping to preserve the
environment which is why I also created
the green tech festival which is really
centered around preserving the
environment and I think Corona also
actually gave us a great opportunity to
see where we need to get to because if
we look at like some of the NASA images
from China
it's phenomenal you can all see them
online it's phenomenal
how the whole the whole emissions and
smog just dropped down like unbelievably
in the short space of time where
everybody was just staying at home it
was incredible and that's really giving
us a guideline to where we need to get
to and that's where technology comes in
because technology is what is what is
the tool that's gonna help us get to
them get to where we need to be in terms
of emissions and in terms of appetite
from investors you haven't seen any
lessening of appetite to invest in green
technology during the current crisis now
of course as with everything everything
is just completely at zero nobody's
doing anything and I mean that's
understandable because it's an
incredible shock to everybody in what's
going on and my thoughts really I mean
I'm in a super privileged situation
because we're in our house and in Spain
we have a garden so our kids can have a
good time outside and and I know that we
know that as a fam
so our thoughts are always going out to
to everybody who's affected so so badly
by this virus and particularly in the UK
as well I have so many friends and ex
colleagues who I know are struggling
through this so we're thinking a lot
about all of you in the UK and everybody
else around the world as you say the
situation in Spain seems particularly
paulus right now just give me a sense of
what it's like on the ground there right
now in terms of how - its impacted
day-to-day life well I don't know I'm
not even allowed to go out of my gate
since three weeks so I don't know what's
going on outside and I don't read the
Spanish press but of course from the
international press I know that it's a
it's only second to Italy at the moment
and probably New York being in an
unbelievably difficult situation was
just the whole health system being
overloaded and that's why it's so
important to test and test and test to
be able to to find the cases as early as
possible and to put a really important
team to help to help slow the the rise
in infections you know and that's really
the goal for every nation and I know
that you in Britain as well are now are
now massively trying to reduce the
infection rate going up and that's
what's gone wrong in in Spain in Italy
because it's just too little has been
too too little has been too little has
been done too late because things are
just too extreme